[Music]
Noah Cyrus responds to little Zen
claiming that their relationship was
fake yes actually Simpson in heaven Ross
released their new duet
well Kanye jobs are not safe for work
video as he serves as co-director of the
first ever pornhub Awards
hi you heard that right I know it's not
easy keeping up with Kanye and his
latest collab is not one you would
expect remember when Kanye admitted
having daughters hasn't stopped him from
watching porn no I still like a pornhub
and right well now the rapper has teamed
up with pornhub as the creative director
for the site's inaugural award show
which went down on Thursday in LA the
show was set in the year 69 a teen Kanye
took charge of the makeup and wardrobe
styling and contributed to the design of
the actual statues which I cannot show
you because they were modeled after
imagined alien sex toys
all right well picture this though
because his wife Kim yeah she just
returned to the White House to talk
criminal justice reform
Kim whose rise to fame started with the
sex tape is meeting with the President
and policy leaders while her husband is
designing porn trophies we have
different views sometimes we have
different things but that's my husband
you know at the pornhub Awards which was
live-streamed in VR Kanye also debuted
his latest song I love it with little
pomp spike jonze who also shot the Otis
video directed the not-safe-for-work
visual which features yay and pump and
boxy easy clothes
I can't stop laughing about that but I
want to know what you guys think of the
new Kanye you missed the old Kanye let
me know alright we're gonna keep going
with all the dope new music that just
came out today now a cyrus unveiled her
latest single mad at you off her
upcoming EP now the emotional song comes
after her very recent public split with
rapper lil zan
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm low-key loving this song and Noah's
clearly wearing her heart on her sleeve
on this one she says the EP which is out
September 21st is about dealing with her
emotions and boy are there a lot of them
right now after her very messy and very
public breakup with little zan the young
rapper accused o of cheating I recently
took to Instagram stories claiming the
relationship was a fraud about what we
had was real but I guess it wasn't you
know it was something set up by a
Columbia Records like huh well no it did
not take that sitting down she wrote one
if it was fake why would I be asking you
to come over to hang out why would you
be saying good morning baby
- and what world can I not ask my
boyfriend to promote the song we have
together Cyrus who clearly has had
enough also sent this plea to zan who
she called out by his real name to take
this drama off line Diego please find it
in your heart to end this peacefully and
not on social media and I say no keep
this going because this breakup has me
hooked give the people what they want
and then put it in more music all right
well it is greener pastures for Evan
Ross and Ashlee Simpson the happy couple
just released some new tunes together a
she's first single since 2012 it's a
strip fat trap called I do
[Music]
you asking me
[Music]
thank you and Evan and Ashley's new
reality series premieres this Sunday on
September 9th as we found out they even
got a little help from Evans iconic mom
Diana Ross in the studio kanashii listen
you've sold millions of records around
the world but you've never had Diana
Ross like on your like listening team
did you feel extra pressure monkeys like
super supportive so I feel like let's
her she's like you know on on our team
you know for sure that's nice she
actually came up with the melody that
writing a song too
yeah speaking of fun my last new music
Friday track for you guys is a banger
courtesy of Silk City do Lolita Mark
Ronson and Diplo it's called electricity
[Music]
you know
certified by the daily Denny has a pop
all right guys I am leaving on a jet
plane so I'm heading on an assignment
this weekend Monday there is a special
guest host to be sure you come back for
that I'll see you guys next week I enjoy
a weekend